we thought it might be coming and here
it is a group of Republicans have
started impeachment proceedings against
Deputy Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
and this is how it begins it's just some
Republicans that are starting the
escalation including Republican Mark
meadows and Republican Jim Jordan who
were sort of leading spearheading this
effort what they didn't do yet was force
a vote on the issue and this gives a
sort of temporary break to the
Republicans in the house that are
against this measure because there are
Republicans in the house who say this is
not a good idea this is not what we
should be doing and the explanation for
why they're doing this from Jordan and
meadows is that they're tired of the
Justice Department not giving the men
for information they believe they're
entitled to and the American people are
sick of it and all eleven
representatives who filed the resolution
or members of the house freedom caucus
sort of a very wacky right-wing group of
Congress people and first of all when I
read the list of who's doing this my
immediate thought was Jim Jim Jordan
should be doing anything until we figure
out what his role was in the cover-up of
sexual assault when he was a wrestling
coach
full stop and he's clearly eager for any
opportunity to distract from that and
you know what can I sign on to impeach
Rosenstein sure put my name on it but
the bigger picture is that this is part
of a growing effort to attack rod
Rosenstein obviously with the goal of
interfering in the Trump Russia
investigation and the Justice Department
denies the allegations that they aren't
providing in information they say they
provided everything that was subpoenaed
unless there was a specific reason to
withhold a particular document period
but this doesn't stop some Republicans
like Matt gates from saying things like
there's a mountain of evidence against
Rod Rosenstein and it is actually more
likely I believe that Trump will use the
impeachment articles as a pretext to
fire Rosenstein rather than that the
White House then that the full House of
Representatives rather will actually
vote to do it and even if the House
voted to do it it's still not likely
that the Senate would actually move to
remove move to remove Rosenstein and of
course that's the way it has to work the
house would vote on it the Senate would
actually do it senators I think would
realize
that moving to remove Rosenstein would
not be good for many of their reelection
campaigns in parts of the country in
some places it would be absolutely fine
there are some senators who would suffer
if they actually move to remove
Rosenstein is difficult to say if of
course the House actually voted that way
well especially because impeachment of
federal officials are so rare right yet
maybe happens once every 10 years so if
you're gonna make that case you really
got to bring it and they don't have that
supporting evidence and you have to be
sure I hate that term this is the hill
you want to die on but you've got to be
sure that this is how you want to expend
some political capital right and
fundamentally this is a misuse of power
or it would be if it were carried
forward it's also just the wrong
reaction if you're not getting the
documents you want if you're not getting
the documents you want from the Justice
Department they're not giving them to
you as you claim impeachment is a
punishment but if what you actually want
is the documents there are other ways to
ensure that you get the documents and
that's why this seems like a panicked
reaction maybe to the michael cohen
tapes leaking maybe to something else
and not actually a means through which
you would get the documents you want
because impeachment is a punishment so
what's the end game here that
republicans either force Rosenstein out
or trump fires Rosenstein and then
replace him with a new Deputy Attorney
General who will fire robert muller and
end the trump rushman investigation the
most important part of this is that it
relates to Trump Russia right that
that's that's what this is all connected
to and you're you proposed a couple of
different paths that it could go maybe
there are others and at its core the
most important part of this farce is
that the articles of impeachment cite
things related to Carter pages FISA
warrants from 2016 Rosenstein didn't
become Deputy Attorney General till
April of 2017 so how can you be citing
things that happened before the guy was
in the role as part of the reason why he
needs to go and maybe he's a time
traveler but short of being a time
traveler this isn't even remotely
reasonable and I'm seeing two major
reactions to this or sort of like major
themes one reaction is this is it
Republicans are killing the Trump Russia
probe now it's going to be over within a
month the other reaction is oh no this
is about to escalate to such a degree
that these are the clear last gasps of a
dying presidency and this is the panic
that is setting in I actually don't know
that it's either I think it could go on
like this for a long time a little bit
of a push one way a push in the other
direction with individual Republicans
trying to either make a name for
themselves or in other ways get
attention or or or maybe to get on
Trump's radar as some kind of hero who's
coming to his defense but if you look at
internet articles about this impeachment
resolution you will see the comments
littered with obvious Russian troll BOTS
posts and that's one way of knowing that
this is kind of a big deal when it comes
to the broader investigation we'll
follow it and see what ultimately
happens